whenever I'm asked if I have any dietary
requirements prior to sundew I always
answer yes food but still even I have
cut right down on red meat even bacon
eggs are now bad for us too
we're told no wonder veganism is in
vogue supermarkets are trying to make it
easier for us to avoid animal products
entirely and so do high street fast-food
and bakery outlets cutting out meat
dairy and sticking to a plant-based diet
is one of the most effective choices a
person can make to reduce the suffering
of animals help the planet and improve
personal health say the growing hordes
of adherents to the vegan faith
win-win-win then panel I'm going to try
it even though I live with two men who
opened the fridge I have stocked full of
healthy crunchy green fruit and veg and
slam it shut and complain there is no
eating food I'm on my own at home so
who's going to join me can we get
Gregg's onto the Gregg's of vegan
sausage rolls given the fact that I
start my day with chocolate every day my
favorite we have my favorite foods
Cheers I love Sunday roast dinners I
will not be conversing poppy is vegan I
was here oh you might know animals but
what I feel very strongly about is
choice and if somebody chooses to be
vegan Fairplay to them if that's what
they want to do and that's what they
want to eat you know go for it I do have
a slight issue with them some aspects of
the vegan movement because it is very
aggressive and I think that they seek to
intimidate and I think if you want to
get people to move to veganism not a
problem
do it for education rather than
intimidation and I've been turned off
and the vegan movement because of things
that I've seen so bullying harassment
vandalism attacks on farmers those kind
of things I know that what those people
want to do is raise awareness of
veganism and convert people like me but
they're turning me off maybe and my
final point is I do find the vegan
movement quite confusing in parts
because I don't quite understand why
people are so anti eating meat products
feel a need to replicate the look feel
and texture of meat products with their
alternate things so if you don't want to
eat chicken nuggets don't eat chicken
nuggets
why'd you feel the need there to create
vegan chicken nuggets and vegan sausages
just think it's a bit weird well it's
funny you say that
a Michele because many people claim that
vegan food isn't as nice so we decided
to do a little experiment earlier to
discover if Michele is right or not
a warm welcome to Rachel's kitchen I
hope you're hungry because today Greg
and Michelle we're going to do a blind
tasting of some of the nation's favorite
foods only with a difference you're
going to tell me which ones are vegan
and which ones are not vegan easy
starting with the hors d'oeuvre which is
chicken nugget
which one is non chicken nugget
someone's chicken nuggets first obvious
surely that's the chicken nugget that's
the chicken nugget and this is having a
lot of chicken nuggets in my time they
are chicken nuggets Michele is right
you're wrong now we're going to move to
the main course which is Pete pizza
which one is vegan which one is not
vegan that's hard about so this is the
bigger one and great it's obviously hard
to tell but grekes right that's the
vegan pizza somewhere not only you're
rounding off your meal with some
delicious looking right now you
do they taste different yeah that's
cheese that's cheese
you're both right though they did very
well thank you so much for coming to
Rachel's kitchen
so the takeaway from that for me was I
mean some of it may look like chicken
nuggets and be vegan Nuggets but it
wasn't all bad was it
I don't know like I thought it was all
bad but I both both the chicken nuggets
and the non chicken I couldn't tell them
it's what I discovered it was what an
expert you are on chicken nuggets yes
and I couldn't believe it we both tried
chicken nuggets it couldn't even test
which one was chicken and a chicken look
at that that's me tells me how posh you
are young man oh you weren't so good on
the pizza though doesn't have to go
vegan or vegetarian in moderation is the
key so your flexitarian I use everything
enlarged contacts long novel but if we
if we moderated what we ate in terms of
me just by a little bit it would cut
greenhouse gases by 70%
yeah if we cut out things like processed
food and and snacks and make animal
products you would cut them by 45% which
is exactly what we but you know we can't
be demonizing livestock when hoping the
demand for crops is gonna require more
herbicides more pesticides more
fungicides everything that's gonna put
the environment so it is moderation
ecosystem and I am I fear and I'll show
up in a minute but I fear in this coding
we have a massive problem with food
anyway we have a massive obesity rate
people don't take the time in the
trouble to take care of that diets and
so how do we think that they're gonna go
on a vegan diet and let's let that point
at the fact here there's only six
hundred thousand in the UK which is less
than 1% of the population how do we
think they're gonna do that it's very
complex and to make sure they get all
their their nutrients vitamin b12 which
are vital I in which is vibrating if
they can't be bothered to get afraid I
did find a calorie deficiency the main
problem I thought you did this country
or the cooking so I do most of the
cooking in our house and my dread is
that someone's coming and they phone up
I don't think I could be a true vegan I
was honest I think I would have to be
vegetarian yes well I like the whole
five-day-a-week movement which is you're
vegan for five days and then you eat
meat at the weekends I think that's a
really good way of doing well this is
incremented incredible spike in the
demand for vegan products supermarkets
and also the rollout of vegan product
tonight sorry just one thing to add to
what you just said Rachel I think the
other problem is it's a bit too female
centric at the moment you know you're
talking about the men in your home
feeling that they can't eat anything in
your fridge and I think we have to
figure out a way to bring men around to
the vegan movement because if you look
at the stats in the UK 36% only 36% of
vegans are men and 64% this is what
happens at home is I yeah will produce a
lovely leafy crunchy thing and then
delish good fridge to get some photos I
called truth or scare and I was talking
about if you don't get the combos right
and vegetarian vegan diets it can affect
kids hugely it can impact on their
growth it can impact on their
intellectual development so you have to
be right across your food and devoted
for and about acting and is that right
certain many athletes attorney to
veganism Michel by the way the great
thing about the movement today is you no
longer feel like the odd one out you no
longer feel like you're annoying
everyone if you have to if you're that
one vegan in the group because often
you're no longer the one vegan in the
group that's really helped people
embrace the vegan lifestyle and focus on
everything that they're gaining as
opposed to what they're having to give
up on but veganism is properly in the
mainstream now I mean the wealth of
knowledge around the ethics and the
environmental impact of animal
agriculture as well as just how
nutritious a vegan diet can be is really
widely accessible oh I'm sorry I wasn't
so I think good for her she's made that
choice and she's following it good for
her but you just hear me good bloke
sitting around looking at her and
thinking she needs a good thing yes
there's a guy there's a guy called Dave
Vince who bought a football club and
he's been very successful it's called
Far East Green Rovers but he insisted
that the only food serve there is vegan
food yeah well we interviewed a couple
of fans but I think there should be a
choice I feel like he's pushed upon you
but each to the room his curve he really
makes this different I supposed isn't it
we everybody talks about it yeah I'm not
sure that would go down too well in
Brentford of Willett anyway there's this
time for this this week Sky News
broadcast the world's first live TV news
bulletin from under the sea how
impressive presenters Anna botting and
Mark Austin descended 250 meters below
the Indian Ocean exploring underwater
life in a mini submarine fitted with
cameras to draw attention to the plight
of the world's oceans as quite
spectacular take a guess
it is science it is exploration
it is adventure all combined and has
never been done before
on a live television program this is a
world first our current depth is 4 4 3
feet our heading is you never know quite
what you're going to see all above us it
gets more and more blue down beneath us
it's like a murky brown color it looks
very very forbidding I have to say it is
an alien yet amazing world down below
unnerving but exhilarating and then
there was the small issue of
broadcasting live while down there
I've broadcast from some pretty remote
and amazing places in my time but none
quite so remote were amazing as this it
is quite unnerving in some ways it's
like a moonscape but the bottom of the
sea at this depth there's barely a
glimmer of sunlight what you're seeing
are the lights of the submersible the
ocean is the place where 94% of life on
this planet exists reason enough maybe
to protect the sea the coral it contains
and those that depend on it
that's amazing and perhaps that's why we
should become vegan because just to
protect that on you jealous of them to
be nothing I'm so sad from under the sea
scuba diving I find being under the
water I'm right there I'm so peaceful
and you're just it is a different well
that's beautiful beautifully made